una de las cualidades innatas de la
mujer es su instinto de protección
por ello desde la niñez nuestros juegos
estaban orientados al cuidado de la
familia al cuidado del hogar
el juego de la casita el cuidado de los
bebés con las muñecas la alimentación
con el manejo de la vajilla así podría
citar muchos ejemplos y los hombres el
juego de la pelota los carritos
yo quiero preguntar cuántas de las
mujeres que están acá jugaron a los
bebés con las muñecas jugaron a papá y
mamá cuántas
perfecto
estábamos estereotipadas estábamos
programadas para la tensión del hogar y
los hijos y el hombre para el sustento
pero eso ha cambiado ha evolucionado a
igualdad o trabajamos por la igualdad de
los derechos
eso es cierto parcialmente porque es
falso si hablamos desde el punto de
vista de la exposición a los riesgos
tanto las mujeres como los hombres están
expuestas pero biológicamente y
físicamente son distintas y esto es muy
importante tenerlo en cuenta y ya más
adelante vincularemos este ejercicio
quiero contarles que es de esas
emociones y desde esa experiencia de
vida y mi experiencia de vida
relacionada con el cuidado de la salud y
la protección de las personas y mi
experiencia laboral también relacionada
con la protección y seguridad de los
trabajadores en sus lugares y espacios
de trabajo me tienen hoy aquí para
hablar de un tema que es apasionante
para mí y seguramente para muchas de las
personas que están acá
la inclusión de la mujer en la
prevención
la directora ejecutiva de onu mujer
malambo cuca en su cuarta conferencia
mundial del día internacional de la
mujer el 8 de marzo de este año expresó
ahora es el momento
para referirse
a la oportunidad que tiene la mujer en
este periodo
en esta época una mujer ha referido que
el siglo 21 es el siglo de la mujer
y nosotros podemos evidenciar que en
menos de un siglo la mujer ha tenido ha
venido construyendo espacios importantes
de participación en el medio laboral
en el medio educativo en la
investigación en la cultura en la
política desempeñándose cada vez mejor y
yo estoy de acuerdo con ello las mujeres
estamos escalando espacios muy
importantes para poder defender nuestros
derechos desde nuestros diferentes roles
cifras importantes que apoyan esto
el 49% de la pobla el 49.6 de la
población mundial son mujeres del 7.6
billones de la población
hay una cifra muy importante
el 60 por ciento de la población
femenina en el mundo es analfabeta
que por hecha
qué gran desafío que tenemos todos que
estamos haciendo para instruir educar y
empoderar
y cambiar esta situación les dejo el
interrogante que hace el mundo que hacen
los países que hace colombia que hace la
academia que hace la universidad que
hacemos todos los involucrados
ligado a esta cifra
como las mujeres no tienen esa
oportunidad se casan de manera muy
temprana hay 700 millones de mujeres que
se casaron antes de los 18 años
y el 30 por ciento de ellas son una
tercera parte de ellas menos de 15 años
y autonomía que podían decidir ellos
ellas sobre su situación cuál sería su
situación frente a tomar decisiones y
eso no ocurrió en el pasado eso ocurre
ahora en el siglo 21
eso ocurre en muchas regiones del mundo
llegué a este país en algunas costumbres
en algunas regiones en algunos
comportamientos ocurre la sociedad
no permite es una cultura
que estamos haciendo para ello
decimos
por estas situaciones particulares yo
quiero compartir con ustedes una
historia una historia mi primera
historia laboral
en la floricultura era médica rural
relata esta historia laboral me cambió
la vida
me transformo
desde esa época mis acciones todas mis
acciones y formación han estado
relacionadas con la prevención y la
protección de las de los trabajadores y
trabajadoras en su medio laboral
viví de cerca
todas las desigualdades de género que se
traducían en brechas
identificaba la falta de seguridad
social que tenían las personas el
derecho a la lactancia el derecho a la
vejez
transformó mi mundo empecé quiero
decirles que antes de llegar a eso a ese
mundo laboral de la floricultura yo
quería ser médica pediatra porque ya era
madre porque tenía una historia de niña
y quería hacerlo rápido para irme a la
clínica
pero al vivir de cerca las historias
compartir con ellas las desigualdades
los malos tratos
yo
di una vuelta un vuelco vuelvo y les
digo transformar transformó mi vida mi
actuar mi sentir y yo quiero compartir
con ustedes una historia muy triste la
historia de rosa
rosa una mujer de 40 años madre cabeza
de familia cinco hijos
con una formación mínima con unas
necesidades muy grandes de conservar y
tener su salario para sostener a sus
cinco hijos su vida era un drama todos
los días tenía que dejar a sus hijos a
sus cinco hijos al cuidado de algunos
vecinos o algunos familiares o en el
peor de los casos como lo me lo comentó
alguna vez dejados bajo llave
ese era el drama de todos los días de
estas mujeres de sus riesgos extra
laborales y tenía a las tres y media de
la mañana que levantarse y a las cuatro
y media ella estaba saliendo rumbo a su
trabajo y allá no ella se encontraba con
unos tópicos con unos paradigmas con
unos estereotipos en su mundo laboral
donde se decía que el trabajo de las
mujeres era seguro
no era así
rosa tenía varices en sus piernas
de las 8 horas laborales o más tenía
dolencias en su hombro su codo y su
muñeca porque las condiciones
ergonómicas del sector para quien conoce
no requieren explicación pero más grave
aún los riesgos psicosociales por su
familia pero a los que estaba sometida
por el trabajo por las cajas por lo que
tenía que entregar
pero había un riesgo mayor
la exposición
a plaguicidas a sustancias que las
recomendaciones dicen que una vez
fumigado el cultivo o el área tienen que
regresar al día siguiente
ella y muchas más tenían que regresar
dos horas después
entonces si hablamos que el tópico de
que el trabajo era seguro pues no era
seguro por todas las razones que les
estoy describiendo
ausencia de pautas adecuadas pues no la
sabían porque si hubieran habido
políticas organizativas orientadas para
la prevención de esos riesgos inherentes
o riesgos propios a los que estaban
expuestas pues esas no hubieran sido las
dolencias ni la morbilidad que allí las
enfermedades que ahí se presentaban
efectivamente habían pocos programas de
prevención orientados para minimizar sus
riesgos y también para diferenciarlos
por esa transversalidad de género que ya
les expliqué de las diferencias
biológicas y de la fuerza física entre
diferencias entre mujer y mujer y
también entre mujeres y hombres ejemplo
de ello es la carga física se ha
definido que un hombre sin ayuda
mecánica no puede levantar más de 25
kilos y una mujer no puede levantar más
de 12.5 ahí hay un ejemplo concreto
pocos programas de prevención
por las dolencias por los riesgos por
las enfermedades que presentaba rosa y
muchas de sus compañeras pues no habían
programas de prevención
pero además de toda esta problemática y
casuística rosa tenía un riesgo no
visible
el asedio
permanente por parte de compañeros o por
parte de sus jefes
esto ha llevado este acoso hoy conocido
como ese acoso laboral en el mundo hay
estudios que definen que el acoso es un
tema grave incluso ha llevado a suicidio
de trabajadoras y trabajadores pasan
desapercibidos como cualquier otro
riesgo psicosocial pero no es así
enfermedades atribuidas a las hormonas
buena imaginación rosa no tenía
oportunidad de quejarse ni decirse
porque entonces estaba siendo afectada
por el tema hormonal porque está con la
regla porque el ciclo porque la pone así
porque eso da dolor de cabeza porque
tiene una buena imaginación
pero no porque tiene una sintomatología
que está haciendo evidente rosa no tenía
derecho a quejarse había un rechazo de
las quejas
fíjense ustedes esta es la problemática
de rosa rosa tenía todo para cambiar mi
vida para orientar mis acciones la
recuerdo hoy como si fuera ayer
entonces con toda esta problemática
decidimos trabajar con rosa por ese
conocimiento propio que tenía de su
sector y con otro equipo cambiando y
desarrollando 5 movilizadores para
generar inclusión de la mujer en la
prevención
identificar con rosa a nivel personal y
luego colectivo a qué brechas ellas
estaban expuestas además haga además de
todo lo que les he contado reconocer
cuáles son sus brechas apoyar y
contribuir a las soluciones para generar
unos cambios y poder evolucionar con
respecto a esas brechas así mismo la
intergeneracionalidad poder integrarse
rosa poder integrarse con una población
mucho más joven
recuerden rosa tenía 40 años
pero también en este sector había
vinculación hay incluso ahora
vinculación de mucha mujer tenía
compañeras y compañeros mucho más
jóvenes tenía que integrarse tenía que
aprender de ellos tenía que desaprender
para poder interactuar y está
intergeneracionalidad hoy es vigente en
las organizaciones y está más de moda
que nunca
la multiculturalidad
rosa también tenía compañeras de otras
regiones si estaban en bogotá y
cundinamarca tenían regiones de la costa
de otros en medellín personas que venían
de otros lugares a trabajar en la
floricultura no necesariamente de la
región esa multiculturalidad la llevaba
a aceptar los conocimientos y los pre
saberes de sus compañeros y compañeras
en su organización a interactuar
entendiendo sus diferencias para poder
contribuir a una mejora
y desde la conciencia
el ser desde la conciencia poder
entender sus obligaciones
responsabilidades que no podía exponer
su integridad por unas necesidades
económicas aprender a valorarse aprender
a protegerse a saber a informarse ser
saber para poder tener para llegar para
saber que en su casa la esperaban sus
hijos para saber que tenía que tener que
tenía que tener un liderazgo que tenía
que tener una conciencia pero que tenía
que ser una mujer sana íntegra y de
ejemplo
así mismo poder identificar esas
cualidades que la caracterizaban la
fuerza la energía la tenacidad que se
convertían y que ella debería utilizar
como atributos y cualidades para
resistir para mejorar y para liderar su
situación particular y las de sus
compañeros estos 5 movilizadores fueron
importantísimos y tuvieron un impacto
importante en la en la población
entonces yo quiero dejarles
una recomendación a todos todos todos
debemos trabajar en la movilización de
estos cinco elementos para la inclusión
de la mujer y una última cifra
del 23 por ciento de la población
mundial solo hay de toda la población
mundial sólo el 23 por ciento llega a
ocupar cargos en escaños parlamentarios
a nivel del mundo y sólo el 4% llega a
altos cargos en el nivel directivo
yo soy un ejemplo
y por eso desde mi rol y desde mi
obligación y responsabilidad contribuyó
a diseñar programas actividades para que
la situación de rosa nunca se vuelva a
repetir y les dejo mi frase favorita
toma acción y vive con pasión la vida
gracias
[Aplausos]